at this altitude this episode is brought
to you by 99designs when your business
needs a logo website business card
thumbnail or any other design I
recommend checking out 99 designs I use
them myself I've used them for many
years
I use them to create book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to becoming number one York
Times bestseller I've also used them for
banner ads illustrations and much more
with 99 designs you get a variety of
original designs from designers around
the world give your feedback and then
pick your favorite your happiness is
guaranteed so check out some of my
competitions and designs and some of
your competitions and designs from
fellow Tim Ferriss show listeners at 99
designs com forward slash Tim and right
now you can get a free $99 upgrade on
your first design so check it out 99
designs com forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's what
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is
always my job to deconstruct world class
performers to tease out the habits
routines favorite books toothpaste
whatever it might be that you can apply
and try in your own lives this
particular episode comes from a fun
event my first live podcast which was at
the iconic troubadour in LA I had a
blast I was nervous but you guys sold it
out in 30 minutes through the email
newsletter so thank you thank you thank
you
and if
haven't signed up for the email
newsletter you should check that out
it's free just go to four hour work week
comm forward slash Friday all spelled
out and you can have a taste there were
quite a few amazing guests at the event
and we're gonna divide them up into a
few different episodes the first is a
professional snowboarder and
skateboarder you know who this is
two-time Olympic gold medalist Shaun
White spelled like Shaun of the Dead sha
UN at Shaun White on Twitter and so on
he holds the X Games record for gold
medals at 15 as well as the highest
overall medal count at 24 I believe he
is also the only person to win gold at
both the winter and summer X Games Shaun
has earned the number two spot on
BusinessWeek's list of the 100 most
powerful and marketable athletes and he
has created an incredible business and
life for himself he has made a lot of
smart decisions where many athletes
particularly those who peak at a young
age or become famous at a young age make
mistakes end
achtung for those near LA or willing to
travel Shaun is hosting an incredible
event called air and style this
weekend's think of it as X Games meets
Coachella where you can listen to
world-famous bands and musicians like
Incubus Grammatik one of my favorites
then see jumps off of a 16-story ramp
that's not a joke 16 story among other
excitement so check it out at air and
style.com all spelled out for 20% off
whether that's general or VIP admission
you can use code Tim Ferriss spelled
properly with two hours and two S's I
don't get any cut and I've bought it
myself at full retail for tickets for
myself and friends the code is only good
until midnight Pacific on February 19th
that is Friday for Winnett teeth so jump
on it once again that's air and
style.com
and without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with Shaun White I thought
we could start at the beginning so a lot
of people are not familiar with the
conditions with which you came into this
world the very beginning the birth the
very beginning Shaun let me take you
back
no it's actually a little bit of a sad
story uh you know or just a bit of a
struggle in the beginning you know I was
born with a heart defect
I was called tetralogy fellow so I don't
know - technically what happened but
some of the valves in my heart were
leaking and I had to go in and have
multiple open-heart surgeries in order
to correct this I was known as what's
called a blue baby actually my skin
would was turning blue because I wasn't
getting enough oxygen and so you know my
mom sent me in there multiple operations
they said you're gonna have a sluggish
heart he won't be very active you know
you should be ready for these things and
then you know sure enough like I want to
do that you know I want to go jump off
things and you know run around and I
only had a couple incidents where you
know I like passed out on the soccer
field once or you know III did something
where i overexerted myself and you know
I just I wasn't ready for that but um I
don't know my parents never really told
me I couldn't do anything which was I I
think the reason why I was never feel
fearful you know so I always a I went
out and I would I would do sports I was
you know do whatever the only thing I
was told I couldn't do was scuba dive
scuba scuba dive I don't know why I was
like anomaly of something about like the
air bubble getting I don't know okay
that was a little kid right when did you
first meet Tony Hawk man Tony Hawk
I was and I was probably like 5 years
old or something like that he would come
to the local skate park I was just lucky
enough to grow up in Delmar was the area
and he skated at the local YMCA
in Encinitas and so I would go there and
he would just be there so I got to kind
of like say hi and watch him do his
thing and you know it's one of the best
ramps in town he grew up skating delmar
I never I was another age group that got
to skate this cement park that they had
but there's a very famous skate park at
dumb Mar and so I ran into him all the
time and I was a little fearful to talk
to him it was Tony Hawk so I never
really like said much to him I just
wanted to impress him enough my skating
that he would come talk to me one day
and say yeah he finally came to me and I
was like yes do you remember what move
attempt that move got him to finally
break the ice and come over I can't
recall it was it was probably doing a
McTwist which is a trick invented by
skateboarding named Mike McGill and it's
it's like a front flip while spinning a
540 so 540 is degrees of rotation you
know if you take a full circle is at 360
so we'll keep adding up
no so I started to learn and he owned
company birdhouse skateboards and so is
my dream not only do once he then talked
to me in my mind he was then gonna ask
me to ride for a skateboard company I
had it all worked out so you know he
finally came up to me and we became
friends and he invited me to come do
some demos with him because he was doing
these you know hey we're gonna show up
and we're gonna we're gonna skate and
you know sell skateboards for birdhouse
and things like that and I was kind of
like the token little kid on the ramp
but I was learning at the time better a
better trick so I I slowly became you
know a really really good rider either
skaters is it fair to say and I mean you
might even use this weren't already but
that he was mentor to you you
for a very long time or is that not the
right is that not the right label you
know he really he wasn't he wasn't I
mean that's that's the funny thing is he
never really kind of like sat me down
and gave me a certain advice it wasn't
like hey wasn't Yoda imparting yeah you
should you should make your own you
should do this I mean it never really
was him telling me what to do or advice
anything he was just actually the only
guy going through everything that I was
just about to go through
I mean his video game came out he just
landed his 900 at the X Games and he was
used world famous and people would
approach him and I was just sitting
stand by a witness to all this like well
how did he talk to his fans and like oh
he's still normal guys like he's eating
the dirty ice out of the limousine
minibar he was just the same guy oh
that's cool like I was eating eyes I was
a kid you know as a kid I was just like
looking up to him and he was doing it
but he was great he was a family man at
the time and so that's something that
really kind of allowed us to become
friends at least in my eyes cuz he was
he was this like untouchable figure and
then he asked me to come to a demo once
there to go on that actually was the
Tony Hawk gigantic skate park tour which
I was just like baffled I was just
amazed he actually asked me to go on
this I never get into his house he had
this big house and the gate opened up
but my mom's like just go in like okay
and I like wander in there and you know
he had a couple nice cars and it's like
back when like having a TV screen and
your car was just the craziest thing
ever and he had a Playstation in the
glove blop in the glove box I you know
kid I was just like this is just
incredible and all I remember is I go to
grab the remote you know the controller
and it was just sticky
and I was like what there's like jelly
on it there's like and then there's like
then I'm looking on like clouds like
there's chips buried in the seats and I
was like ah man there's like a car seat
as I go this is a dad he's a dad another
exclusive no it just brought him down to
reality I was like oh he's a dad he's
got to deal with kids and these things
and it allowed us to become friends I
took him as a person rather than is like
untouchable guy so that's how he really
influenced me growing up he never really
kind of steered me in any direction he
was just someone to be observed at that
time at that young age he is I haven't
spent a ton of time with Tony but we
were in Ethiopia for a brief period of
time for charity water and he was just
the most down-to-earth guy and similar
to to David Blaine the loser ski cannot
stop doing magic I mean if he goes on a
plane ride he's walked through the lobby
like he can just like we cannot stop
really at like any dinner party it's
great the babies cannot stop and walk
and he would carry his skateboard
everywhere and this is the middle of
nowhere in northern like TK die
Ethiopia and he's carrying and anytime
he found a patch of anything approaching
asphalt or rideable yeah I would get out
of the car and he'd want to introduce
kids to being on a skateboard for the
first time it was the coolest thing cool
any of this like 15 20 times but very
down-to-earth guy
I brought all the fame and all the
attention took you like three hours to
get back to the hotel my my mom is a was
a waitress and she worked at the Hilton
Hotel at Torrey Pines is now the shirt
no it was the Sheraton it's now the
Hilton and my dad worked for the city of
San Clemente and the water department
and I don't really know what that means
I just I'm pretty convinced he was the
guy that like had the road map out was
like actually he was like fixing main
breaks and all sorts of things that were
going on but we always whenever I asked
my mom she's like he's sleeping he's
he's sleeping on the job
pretty harsh okay siblings I have an
older brother and an older sister I've
actually two older sisters and and an
older brother so I'm the youngest but
but the two so there's my sister carries
one year older than me and then my
brother Jesse who is a half-brother
who's a seven years older and then you
know I have a sister named Jessica who I
don't I don't see as much so she's kind
of the one that's like that's why in the
beginning I got a brother and a sister
so she's a half-sister and she's great
but we don't we don't
don't worry yeah when when you started
to get attention at such a young age and
I'm just looking at these notes tell me
if these are accurate because I know
there's a lot of inaccuracy on the
internet so Burton sponsored since 7 or
a relationship with Burton Sienna am
seven years old and then of course I
continued then after that did your
parents do anything or say anything in
particular to keep you grounded or from
just going off the rails right because a
lot of people who get attention that
young end up kind of flying off the
rails um I don't know it was a strange
circumstance because like
you know I was sponsored by Burton but
it wasn't the biggest I mean it was a
really amazing thing but it it was the
circumstance of just like the right
place in the right time Burton
Snowboards was actually coming out with
a whole line of kids products and they
needed kids to ride their board so I
thought we got a local kid here and
he'll read your stuff and then a local
kid there and so I was kind of like part
of the development team we were testing
products doing all these things for them
but I remember the encouragement was
they're like we'll give you this free
snowboard you keep riding we'll give you
another one and so it didn't really like
I mean as a kid like it's all the
motivation you need to get into this
next snowboard but uh you know I lived
in San Diego area there's not much snow
I mean if you were like you know I had
my whole life on the mountain and then
I'd come home and I'm like walking to
school like everyone else I was like
doing homework and walking walking the
dog like doing normal things so I never
really got to kind of like have my head
you know blown up because I never lived
in the mountains where like I guess kids
that knew you were sponsored would think
that was very cool and that was very
whatever it was until I got older that I
got a really big trip you mean literally
a metaphor I tried to deglaze it for you
guys I have a not blinding anyone like I
mean your question was about me me you
know letting it go to my head I guess
you know my parents are really great at
making sure you know I just had a normal
childhood in that sense like you know I
was doing the snowboard stuff which was
cool and all but they're like you got to
do your homework you got it you know
they were they were encouraging with the
snowboard but they kept me in line when
I came home so looking at your career
it's it strikes me and there's a great
profile that people haven't seen it
Fast Company did a while back but that
you've you've made some very smart
decisions that have allowed you to have
a lot of longevity and to avoid a lot of
the pitfalls and I think athletes but
just general people in the public eye
can you talk about how creative control
and those types of approvals yeah came
to be um no it's a great question I mean
I feel very fortunate that I was able to
grow with you know my success within the
spore you know it started here the free
snow board and then it became hey we'll
give you a travel budget to get around
to your competitions and then I actually
started getting paid to snowboard and I
went pro and these things and sorry I
got a little lost while we're talking oh
I do this all the time when did you
realize that you needed to make this
yeah no I'm sorry so I totally got lost
there scuse me
no so what happened was you know I was
growing with the success and and so
sponsors were coming to me and asking
hey we want to do this ad we want to put
you in this commercial spot or these
things and I'll never forget the day
this kid came up to me and asked me to
autograph this poster for him and I'm
looking at the poster and I'm like I
look horrible in this photo was just
terrible like the worst photo ever and
your ear I was young I was like super
sensitive about how you know you're like
the only redhead around as like how this
just won't work and so oh all I remember
is I signed this poster for this kid and
I'm thinking now he's gonna put it on as
wall his friends are gonna see it this
is just awful
and it's so but but the product in the
shot was amazing I mean this thing you
snatch it off the page and drink it it
was just look so good
and I'm like this isn't fair like you
know I wanna I wanna I want to change
this I want to be able to prove these
things and I asked my agent at the time
about it and I my parents is like what's
up with this and he said oh you want the
right you want to look through all these
and actually approve though I'm like
yeah I want to be a part of that I want
to know what's going out with my name on
it and that that was like my slow intro
to having more control of you know the
imagery and my likeness and and all of
those things that come out that I'm
endorsing I can say yeah remember
somebody told me about their like it
takes 10 or 20 years to build a
reputation and was one bad decision with
that type of thing there completely it
Peto it what are some of the who are
some of the business mentors that you've
had or career mentors or role models for
that matter I was really fortunate when
I was younger to come across an agent
named Mark Irvine IMG and he was a
really great guy I mean we worked
together for probably eight years or
more but he was really someone that I
looked to and he's like you know we
could do these things and and we can we
can you know work with these companies
and we won't even do the deal until we
have the approvals and and kind of like
we put ourselves out there to where you
know we wouldn't even get the deals
unless unless we knew they wanted to
like work with me not tell me how to you
know do what I do but he was a great
mentor in that space and it was funny
cuz my mom I mean when he tells the
story it's pretty good because my mom
asked him to represent me and he said no
because he was really busy he had all
these other big clients and and then he
I think he went back and like check me
out on line he's like oh there's kids
money might be on to something and he
came back to meet me and he said he
didn't want to meet with me and my mom
he just wanted to meet with me he's like
I'll never forget it I realized how
young you were because you sat down in
order to milk so you know he was a great
guy he taught me a lot of important
lessons and things along the way and and
I don't know I feel like I always had a
bit of a excitement about I always
wanted to know more and my mom is
definitely someone that's influenced me
you know it probably way more than
anybody you can imagine I mean she was
the one that was driving I obviously my
father as well but my mom was at the
time she was my mom she was my business
manager she was kind of my agent she was
you know making sandwiches she was doing
everything and so you know I really so
thankful that she was there at that
pivotable you know that important time
in my life what has been and we don't
the name names necessarily unless you're
comfortable with it but would have been
some of the artists opportunities to say
no to that you're glad you said no dude
oh man
bobble heads bobble hands can you
imagine it was like that was a real one
I turned down I was like
I bet I saw someone else's bobblehead I
was the one that got away you know it
was uh I'll probably I'll probably end
up doing this in a year which is well
look back at this and laugh but oh you
could have different versions but then I
was like sixteen and that we should do
the Shaun White fragrance I was like
what
like is it winter fresh like what is
this I just did it and I was blown away
at the amount of money they were willing
on for me and I was just like yeah they
had sweat what are we gonna call this
like I don't know what to do and so I
remember I remember turning it down and
that was a crazy time cuz I was like
well I don't think I'd ever could have
ever my wildest dreams imagined turning
down this amount of money you know yeah
I mean as a kid growing up and like my
family and I like to make ends meet we
would camp out in this van at the
mountains we my mom and dad bought a van
and then they took it down to Tijuana to
get it reupholstered because it had like
crazy amounts of fleas it was used as
like a lookout a car for the police I
can't I can't make this so they took it
down to Tijuana had it reupholstered and
like flea bombed it and then like this
was our home we would go up to the
mountains and like and now I'll sob just
turning down this massive amount of
money to not do a fragrance but you know
those were important things and I feel
like at the time you know as many things
I said no to there was a nice list of
things that I was currently involved
with and and I was like you know what
for every one of these there's probably
there's probably a couple more down the
line that are the real deals that you
want to wait for and you know if it was
meant to be would have been you know it
would have made sense it was any
particular reasons you said no to that
or a particular thinking as to why that
didn't make sense be at the time yeah
just I just was like I can't picture it
on the Shelf I can't picture me standing
in front of a crowd like yourself trying
to like look it's great I mean I can the
dog loves it and
people like how am I gonna promote this
and how it doesn't really you know I
didn't even use deodorant at the time a
lot of fragrance heavy but yeah so it
just didn't make sense and I had to
really ask myself is this something I
can pull off is this something that's
gonna you know kill my cred and and
think about I mean the world of
snowboarding was a very core group and
at that time especially it was like very
touchy scenario to be in to be doing big
endorsements with you know corporate
America so if looking back at say Torino
and when it seems like you're just
suddenly thrust in front of the largest
audience and and had the greatest
awareness compared to previously what
advice would you give yourself have good
advice now would you give that Sean
Whyte oh man that's a tough one I I
would say it's a template because I'm a
firm believer in the fact of all those
made mistakes that I made at that point
got me to this place and I wouldn't
really have learned my lessons and
things I would have told myself to just
kind of like enjoy it more you know it
was a really to be honest it was it was
one of the hardest times in my life I
mean I just won the Olympics it was an
amazing like we did it you know and my
family and in a you know in the
community that we lived in you know I
had a someone yelled Bob Burnquist
earlier over here here we go you know
there's a skateboarder Bob Burnquist and
I had crashed into him during a
demonstration I fractured my skull I
broke my hand I broke my foot I had to
go to school you know immediately after
this like crazy accident and the teacher
saw me and like cried at the sight of me
and I'm like looking around
like why does everybody look so nice
this is great everyone's dressed up it
was picture day I was like okay like I
had these huge black eyes from the from
the head trauma and all these things
school use the picture in your eye like
one of these like massive black eye yeah
dirty t-shirt just looked like a victim
of mugging yeah
sorry I got a little lost somewhere I
was going with that was oh no I was
talking about advice to advice to myself
when I was younger
oh yeah
no we were talking about like the
community that I grew up in and they
didn't really understand when I did
they're like okay he goes yeah that's
cool he goes up to the mountains and
like you know they asked my parents do
you smoke weed like you know my mom what
are you know boy who smokes weed right
and like you know people in the
community just didn't really understand
and so there's a big difference between
holding up X Games medal and a gold
medal from the Olympics I mean everybody
understands that and can recognize that
accomplishment so it not only kind of
like took the people that said I was
gonna be nothing and that I was you know
never gonna make it in this Ford and the
teachers that didn't support me and all
is it really admit that we had succeeded
and so I don't know it's it's kind of
what do you do next
you know I'm 19 I just like we did it
and now what I'm like I gotta do we
should try to do it again I guess like
what it you know where do you get that
same fight you know you'd won the fight
it's like what's next and so I had a
really hard come down from that I didn't
know what to do with myself then I had
an undefeated season when I won that
that year in 2006 and so I was like I
got second place at the event
then the following season I was like
well this year's already not as great
it's the last one and you know I was
really hard on myself and so that was a
time where I would look back and tell
myself to just obviously you know let
things happen and refresh now that I'm
older and I've competed the Olympics I I
know what that that comedown feels like
I'm prepared you know if I click this
last Olympics I was like win or lose I'm
gonna go play some music with my friends
like that's what I really want to do but
at that time it was really tough and I
was dealing with the new success and
fame from the Olympics and endorsements
and money and and what to do and I was
19 I mean like normally you move out of
home when you're 18 you go to college
you go to I was still at home with my
mom like okay cool the like now what
like I didn't I was like I guess I could
buy a house that'd be cool like let's
move out well the plot thickens because
the house we were in I actually owned
know you I purchased the house as an
investment you know and and when you're
18 you can't actually even know I'm
sorry before you're 18 you can't
actually even own anything you can't
like write things off in your taxes you
just get slammed and so I my parents
like it looked shady in the beginning
but they took the money they bought the
house and then they put it back into my
name under a trust and things as
complicated but anyway so as I got all
those like you know what I love you guys
is you did this such a great thing by
supporting me my whole life I just want
to let this like you just stay in this
house and live here I'm gonna go get a
new place and that was a whole new you
know like just growing just growing up
at that time is tough and then to add
all those extra things on top of it was
even more overwhelming you mentioned
enjoying it I remember hearing an
anecdote from Neil Gaiman who's one of
my favorite writers and he became very
well known from Sandman I don't know if
anyone here is as seen in the comic book
or the graphic novels have it it's
amazing and so just sort of reinvented
the genre of the graphic novel and he
was doing this long signing one point
I'd like that the first peak in his fame
and Stephen King was like enjoy it and
he's like yeah I didn't he's like I just
didn't enjoy it I was too overwhelmed by
all these new
actors si si you seem you seem like
you've done a very good job of educating
yourself from many different sources and
I I in the course of trying to prepare
for this heard that you are a fan of the
Andre Agassi autobiography yes that is
read a book incredible book open I
recommend it to everyone why why are you
such a fan of that book it was
incredible I mean well I was a fan of
Andre Agassi just in anyways I had read
an interview that he didn't stretch
before competitions I never stretch
before competitions like I just loved
one just thought the guy was so cool and
he he had like the white Lamborghini
with the headband just yeah and I just
remember seeing that as a kid again this
guy's he's got go he's got something
like he's doing it right you know and I
just I just thought he was so great and
I remember after the Olympics we got a
phone call from Steffi Graf and my my
team manager for the company was like
gee I just got off the phone with Steffi
Graf like Andre is a huge fan he wants
you to come out and you know have a
hangout during his birthday and go
snowboarding so we became friends after
that it was really great and so he sent
me the book when it came out I was like
oh this is great I read the book and man
I really enjoyed the book it was so
amazing to hear his story and his kind
of like struggle of not enjoying this
board and and and then finally finding
his love for it and I don't know it's
just an interesting way he told the
story and I compared so many things of
that to my life and and and I think that
the part that I enjoy the most is that
once he realized that his life wasn't
tennis and that it was his family and it
was his foundation he actually played
better he stopped he got that little bit
of like I don't care I'm gonna play my
heart out I'm gonna go home to people
that love me and people that you know
care about me and and that was something
that I've always felt my whole life is
that like I snowboard for sure I love it
I do it but that's not my life I mean my
life is as many things it's
that's one great amazing facet of my
life but that's that was something that
I was like wow you know I really relate
to that because when I come home I have
a whole different you know world of
friends and things that I'm interested
in and music and art and you know all
these things and so I really enjoyed
that part of it and how open and honest
he would obviously book open how honest
he was about everything and and you know
the ups and downs and yeah it was really
cool I've never had so many people come
up to me I was reading a paperback and
want to talk to me about the book I was
reading okay just like airplanes
restaurants yeah and you mentioned in a
sense of not letting tennis be his
entire identity and then like better
remember this master negotiator said
that he wants he goes he who cares less
wins yeah but there's a there's a really
fine line right because you have to be
driven you have to take it seriously but
if you have all your chips kind of it in
one area and you have an off day then it
like destroys your some worth what do
you what have you done when you've lost
some of that enthusiasm but you're still
in a competition mode how do you how
have you resurrected that or addressed
it referencing the book he had an
amazing quote which I'm gonna probably
butcher right now but he said the
feeling of winning doesn't feel as
strong or last as long as the feeling of
losing no but it's very true it's very
true like you can win something and be
like that was great
1x but like when you lose something it's
just like this it just weighs on you and
everything isn't it shiny and bright
everything is just kind of weighed down
by this and you won't let it go you know
and it's it's amazing it so in my mind I
always kind of twisted things in my
favor I always kind of like made it to
be what I wanted it to be so if I would
show up at a competition and win I'll go
okay great I'm exactly where I need to
be this is what I'm doing and if I
didn't win I would just turn it in my
favorite like well now you know exactly
where you need to be you've seen what
the best are doing and you need to now
one-up that and
you know if you look at something and
kind of try to see that other side of it
you know I would get motivated from that
you know I would use it in my favor to
go compete and go get better and do all
those things so you know that's what
kind of got me through it I guess but I
just had this will to always you know
win to be the best I mean a lot of it
stemmed from the fact that I was told
even the heart condition and all these
things that I wasn't really gonna amount
to much so it was like I it wasn't so
much of I want to do this it's like I'm
I have to do this there was an amazing
situation where I was in Japan at this
competition called the Toyota big air
and I was I was like a wildcard entry so
I was paying my travel to get there with
my mom flew out with me and you know
we're paying for the hotel or paid for
the food all these things all the other
riders were invited so when they got
there they got paid some you know per
diem money to show up and then there's a
big prize purse of $50,000 everyone went
out that night and partied like crazy
and I was kids at home you know at the
hotel with my mom they show up hungover
to the event and they're like you know
the jumps just lame it's not it's just
nobody so it was lame and it's not cool
and you know we don't want to compete
today we're just gonna do a demo we're
all gonna split the money and like I'm
doing the quick math and like man this
doesn't even cover our flights out and
so I was like I don't want to do it I
don't want to split the money and they
like hazed me and they're like oh you're
all about the money
your mama blood I just sat there like
I'm riding really well today I'm not
doing it it you know they had like a big
picture of all the riders faces and
they're drawing dollar signs in my eyes
I was 15 man like that was intimidating
I was like my heroes like making jabs at
me and man i won
yeah it was it was $50,000 in a car was
15 I was like I like the best photo in
the world because I have it all laid out
on the bed because I thought it was so
cool like I mean you just shake money
yeah the best photo ever because I have
a peanut butter jelly sandwich eat my
sandwich I don't know that was just one
demonstration of like me being confident
in my riding knowing what I was there
for and I wanted to win I mean people
wanted to know it why didn't you get you
know pulled into drinking and drugs and
these things and I didn't have time for
me and I wanted to win I want it to be
the best and and nothing could really
get in my way what do you think the
sources of that strength and pace of
that type of peer pressure mean that's
not usual for 15 year old especially
when you're being faced by your idols or
suddenly you know throwing darts at you
did that come from
your parents or is it just something
internally that you've always had or is
there a different answer I think it was
both you know I'd put in the work I'd
put in the time I felt like I was the
best rider and and these guys had their
travel paid to get there they were all
doing even and you know I just felt like
you know what this is my day and I'm not
gonna let them ruin it and I and I I've
worked toward this goal and and you know
I usually set goals every single season
I set a goal it's either like something
very serious and it's usually two goals
it's something very serious and
something funny something stupid what
would be an example of the one of them
was to win the Olympics and then one of
them was to see how many cars I could
win nobody cars
how many cars cuz at the time the
automotive it is they were just like
handing out cars
you I was like okay I got my car in
Japan that's great and I saw I was on a
roll and and I think by the end of the
end of the run I had like nine cars and
they weren't right they'd somewhere they
weren't there was like a Suzuki Sidekick
like mm I like this Volvo and a Jeep and
a you know these random cars but that
was like one of my goals like how many
cars can I win you know I ended up like
donating them at the end you know I had
to pay taxes on all these things all
right like somebody sitting like that
I do yeah they're always random and the
Vancouver Olympics I'm telling you this
I had my goals were to again when the
Olympics and then the other goal was to
wear these pants and the pants that I
had made were these American flag pants
I saw this photo of Axl Rose wearing
something similar they were probably a
little more snug and shorter I was like
I can't pull that but I'm like I could
make some pants like that and yeah it
was just like the stupid go like man if
I won like maybe I don't know like I
could get on the cover on stone or
something like that I had been on the
cover when I first won the Olympics and
had this like ridiculous nickname that
I've been given the tomato and all these
things like that's so not cool like I
got it if I went again what if they put
me on the cover and what if I'm in
American flag pants like doing some Axl
Rose type something and so that was my
goal I had the pants like made and then
tailored up at the Vancouver Games and I
and I've I've won so I could wear the
pants did you wear them while you were
competing or was that just a celebration
I was just celebratory pants for after
these are all true stories and then I
got on the cover for only stone wearing
those pants that's amazing you visualize
the dream and the goal and then you make
it happen but that's what's fun is it
takes a lot of the pressure off of it
winning the Olympics is a very big goal
it's a very stressful goal to have you
know so it's nice to have something else
to like obviously if I won all these
cars that meant I was gonna win the
Olympics as I was winning all the events
you know if I get to wear the pants it
means I won the Olympics it's like it
kind of downplays a whole you know
magnitude of it so that's why I do it
did you come up with out yourself
unless they were cool pants did you come
up with that yourself or did you bum
enough from someone else you did no I
just kind of like mm-hmm
everything was so serious at the time
and I don't know that was just kind of
my way of dealing with it when you're
getting ready to compete and I was just
watching some of your video today and it
struck me how relaxed you seemed and it
seemed and just even in the lane the
landings in particular I was paying
attention and what you saying to
yourself if anything when you're up
there kind of at the gate about to be
released for your run what is woody what
is your internal dialogue er I don't
think there's anything that could be
repeated at such polite company
I usually I'm not really thinking about
anything and that's the beauty of music
they play some music at the top you
start singing along and then I go down
my run and I'm usually just kind of like
humming along to the song and the goal
is to like you're completely focused and
then there's that bit of like not caring
and that allows you to then just do the
tricks like you practice you know what
to do do your own worst enemy at that
point because if you overthink it you
know you're gonna you know like a couple
questions ago is like where am I going
with this and then I forgot what the
question was like you know you can't let
yourself you know get in the way of what
you're trying to do and so I always
describe it like I'm thinking of
you know each wall so I'm doing my flips
and thinking about the next trick so
that's a way to kind of like avoid over
analyzing this landing or something like
that the tough part is it's the last hit
because there's no more hits after that
so there's a really funny video of me at
some competition it's really cold out
and you can see my first hit I'd do my
big trick and there's this big puff of
breath cuz it's so cold out you can see
my breath and then the next trick comes
I do my thing up of breath all the way
down in that last hit there's no breath
I was holding my breath to make sure I
land that trick you know it's always
that uh you know that flow you get that
that kind of like one hit to the next
and I really can't pinpoint one specific
moment out and usually at the top I'm
just kind of like I don't know I'm
usually there I probably just say a
little prayer and kind of I I think I I
say who cares I do I go who cares what's
in the end of the day like who cares
like what's you know what's the big deal
I'm I'm here I'm gonna try my best and
who cares like I'm gonna go home and my
family's there and like the Andre Agassi
reference and who cares I'm gonna I'm
gonna go on from this you know even
though I'm so my whole world's wrapped
up in this like who cares it's very very
stoic in the most positive way it
reminds me also I was interviewing
Triple H the professional wrestler Paul
Levesque and he spends with Floyd
Mayweather before one of Floyd's
championship fights Floyd invited him
into the locker room where his goodness
warm up with stuffing as well I don't
know I don't interfere or weren't bother
you while you're getting and getting in
your head and getting ready to fight he
goes you're not bothering me it's like
if I'm not ready I'm not ready I'm
saying it already I'm ready it's like
there's nothing I'm gonna do in the next
ten minutes is going to make a
difference are there any other books
that have that that you particularly
love or given other people the book I've
given the most
it's called Fifty Shades of chicken it's
a cookbook okay delicious and it's got
this this life and I love chicken I love
it's got this chicken all tied up
besides that the outliers Malcolm and I
can't I can't quote the whole book cuz I
kind of I I'm sorry but I read half of
it says I my attention span wanders and
but I kind of stopped just because I I
really I was reading it and and I really
enjoyed the book and I I you know I
actually just left it on the plane wise
not just but another one but uh and
harrypotter know so I was reading the
book and I was amazed about the story
about the hockey players and in this
kind of anomaly and the in the system
and I started applying that to my own
life Wow well people would think I was
at a disadvantage growing up in Southern
California I was like well I don't find
that as a disadvantage at all it was
probably sunny you know a nice out the
majority of the year or the winter
season you know our winters aren't like
you know somewhere Colorado or Vermont
so the amount of days I could actually
go ride will probably double or triple
the amount of someone growing up
somewhere else and then at the same
moment the person that was building the
parks at Bear Mountain and summit it
snow summit resort you know it was like
this small mountain so they're like oh
yeah do what you want you snow where is
good do what you want and this guy was
building these amazing jobs this amazing
halfpipe he now builds all of the
courses for the world's best events
that's where he got his start at these
mountains you know they were gonna let
him go to Aspen and like tear up the you
know the groomer trail or whatever so
you know that happened and then another
thing I compared to my life is that the
half pipe that they had had a t-bar I'd
like a tow rope at it so sinking Wow the
amount of days now that I'm riding
because it's sunny and the amount of
runs I'm getting because I don't have to
unstrap and hike back up I would just do
my trick get back on the chair and go
back up I was like wow I'm packing in
like you know months of training in
these small windows compared to someone
else that lives in in Vermont or
something where it's like but low weight
well below freezing and they're hiking
the pipe they're tired that's you know
when you're cold it's like it's
frightening to go okay I'm gonna try
this flip you're not super intimidating
I like it's cold you want to go home and
get warm like I was in these conditions
where the snow was soft I got some guy
building the best terrain around and
yeah so there's a lot of fun things that
came into play especially Burton
Snowboards just happened to come out
with the snowboard line so a lot of fun
things you know that I was able to apply
to my life from that book how is your
physical training since we're talking
about training and practicing it was
your physical training changed or
evolved I'm actually doing it now
you have you have I'm stranded
yeah no it's it's strange I I what I do
is floor it I consider myself an athlete
but I've never really treated myself
this one especially when you're 16 you
know you just bounce back like are you
you're younger you try these tricks you
don't have to work out I I'm like we're
taking the chairlift we're going down a
hill I'm not like you know going up
against someone that's twice my size and
I got to deal with that it's it's
definitely like an individual sport and
it relies on the element of being
creative you know I can come up with a
brand new trick that no one's done
before and be the best in the world
where it doesn't matter how hard I hit
the gym I still have to be inspired and
then have the you know the guts to go do
this trick and perform it and you know
master it but uh recently I watched a
documentary called seven days in hell
and I was like oh this is funny this is
really great but below that was the
actual doc it's a mockumentary with Andy
Samberg and Jones and one of the guys
from jon snow from Game of Thrones and
I'm sorry yeah great actor and so really
funny film right below it was the actual
documentary Bjorn Borg in John McEnroe
and somehow I got to watch this and I'm
watching and John was I'm sorry Bjorn
you know had his trainer wake him up
somebody was hitting balls with him the
other guy is stretching him and I was
like he's got this whole team this is
amazing like why don't why don't I have
that why don't I do that in like this is
it's just probably like a couple months
ago and so I was like I got on the phone
it's like okay I need a trainer
and I need this this girl to travel with
me and help me stretch and Swan you you
know get my back fixed from the plane
and and it sounds so ridiculous to me
now that I don't I didn't do it before
you know my eyes were just opened by
seven days of Hell which is pretty funny
but yeah so I was like I what I did
before is I would just show up in a city
and I just roll the dice and be like hey
do you know anyone that's good at
physical therapy or massage and you get
the one that's like
they're just not they're not doing
anything you know I go that was great
thank you you know it or do you get
somebody that's like this is Shaun White
like I got impress this guy in one
session yeah although I can barely walk
after the thing so I was like hesitant
to even get training and I was like well
you know my back so locked up it's
really helping like me stick my landings
yeah it was crazy and so I just recently
decided you know wow why don't I take
this into my own hands and obviously I'm
getting older and yeah it was something
I really wanted to do and and it's made
it so much easier surprise but yeah it's
it's something I don't know I just I
didn't really think about it and yeah
I'm 29 I was like I should probably what
is there any particular type of training
or piece of that training now that you
feel has helped you the most yeah
and when I say I didn't train I mean
there were moments from like okay like
I'm gonna make sure for this month I
really like hit the spin bike or I'll do
this or there is various trainers where
I would meet up with them and then you
know we we'd hit it for maybe a couple
weeks and then I'd fizzle out cuz I
would go on trips and things and um the
only really time I did go to the gym was
after injuries I hurt my mean and it
freaked me out I was like wow I gotta
hit the gym I gotta really protect my
knees and my things that are gonna keep
me in the sport but the training that I
find now that really helps was its
balance and core and if I can't say it
to visualize my runs and things you know
to picture myself I'm very visual like I
know what I'm gonna see when I hit the
jump I know what the the landing is
gonna look like I know what you know
who's gonna be waiting at the bottom of
the of the run to you know high five me
you know good job but all these things I
visualize everything down to the pants
I'm gonna wear literally it gets pretty
involved and so you know I feel like the
training when you're thinking about you
know those positive outcomes and you're
thinking about what you want to do what
you want to achieve wall training is a
very powerful thing and then
yeah just just just simple simple things
that I should have probably been doing
for a long time now that when you're
coming up on an important competition
out of water and not at the gate but in
the hours preceding that what is your
what are your rituals look like or
routines I don't know I made my mom she
was very superstitious and and so like I
wasn't in the beginning and now it's
slowly rubbed off on me cuz I would come
home or I come back to the hotel my
whole room was packed up my whole bag
was packed up like these maids are
really going for that extra extra mile
here like what's going on and so she was
like oh if I sneak in your room and pack
up your bags it means you're gonna be
safe and you're gonna win the event all
right lady like you know and so I
remember you know I won and then I won
the next one and I'm like no there I am
packing my bag on a break tradition but
nowadays like the things I do is I tend
to eat a steak before I compete the
night before some skateboarder told me
he does it I tried it i won now I have
to eat a snail you're locked in the
spins yeah yeah which is pretty crazy
because I didn't eat a steak before
Sochi really yeah but you oh you did not
eat a steak that no not eat a steak
that's when you picked up the
superstition kinda like your training
but yeah so there's like a bunch of
things like it that Bess you want before
Sochi not having totally they were like
five of those things that I'm talking
about that all took place before the
event it's not because I didn't want
steak I didn't all of a sudden be like
you know what you know I was just like
you know they didn't even know if they
were gonna run the competition you know
leading up to the event we had three
days of practice and the half height was
unraidable for three days and so the
meeting that night was to decide if they
were even gonna do the event the next
day which is a very tough scenario as a
competitor because you're like alright
tomorrow we're gonna maybe do this
you get all psyched up and yeah it's
like this big maybe and so the meeting
went till 2:00 a.m. and my coach at the
time is the one that cooks the steaks
and he's just like warm Russia when we
find a mistake right now like I'm not
one to break your dish but you want to
do it tonight of all nights you know and
so anyways that that story aside but
yeah there's there's things where I get
I get a song that's played and I have to
hear that same song what size million it
depends I for 2006 it was a CD C's back
in black one was communication breakdown
by Led Zeppelin you know one was a Black
Keys song what was the song Dick Allen
for you yeah so there there's strange
things I was 16 I went to my first
concert ever
it was the Ozzfest I went yeah I went
with my parents
oh this is incredible also my first
cousin yeah and I bought this t-shirt
that said the Prince of [ __ ] darkness
and it was it was Ozzy and flames I was
like this is great and I started wearing
it under my under my Jersey every
competition and I was winning Ozzy was
like you know helping me out it's uh you
know just random things like that so
there's like select t-shirts and songs
and things over time that you know I
kind of you know this could not I
couldn't plan this you bring up the the
Ozzy Osbourne was a prince of [ __ ]
darkness yeah okay it said did you
design a jacket called the most unholy
jacket ever yes can you explain that
what was amazing like at the time I was
I was really young and I was slowly you
know gaining this popularity and so
Burton Snowboards came to me they're
like we want to do a pro model snowboard
boot Wow okay cool like I have no idea
what to do so I asked my older brother
Jesse and he was always very artistic
and he you know we came up with this
like really cool quilted pram and and it
sold out it was amazing hit
we came out with another one and that
grew into you know boots and a board and
helmets and then it became a whole
clothing line at Burton Snowboards
called the white collection and
basically you know that had free rein to
do whatever I want he's like well it
would be hilarious if the tag line was
super long you know we had the tags for
the jackets at the store that was just
like this long I got mom like oh yeah
the most unholy jacket ever that would
be great
so that was pretty much why we named
that have these really long big
obnoxious tags on the Jack were there
any other any other names and of
particular favorites I can't recall
there was some good ones but it was fun
we would always do these strange things
I mean I was always about the little
details so there was a pass pocket that
you have in your jacket that you flip up
and get scanned to go on the chairlift
and there's always his lame photo of
Jake Burton he's not lame just the photo
was lame no offense but I remember
thinking like God they print this out
and make it why don't we do something
really funny in there so we we turned it
into this like my brother figured out
how to take one piece of paper and fold
it until like a little comic book and we
would like display these bizarre
you know like pieces of art and sayings
and things and hairy armpits and just
weird stuff so yeah it was all about
those little details but people
appreciated it you know when you bought
the jacket you were always discovering
like you know an unholy jack and we had
these like one pocket that you would
flip up and it would say that most of
the only jacket everyone on the other
side it was like people dancing in
flames and things it was just fun you
know I really enjoyed doing it and that
was my introduction into designing you
know I I just like getting the right of
approval for my ads and things there's a
natural kind of progression and story to
all these things that I'm involved with
now you know I didn't wake up like I
need my own clothing line like no it was
my brother was amazingly talented artist
we had this great opportunity and we
enjoyed doing it we would make the
drawings on napkins the samples would
get made in China we'd bring them back
make adjustments and then you see
somebody wearing your jacket it's
incredible it's this fulfillment of like
wow he's
in front of this huge wall of clothing
and picked my jacket like that's so cool
you know that that connection there yeah
you you have Minister part of the reason
why I wanted to buy Shaun and everyone
who's been here so far is that you have
you're good at several many different
things and I'm always curious about how
things transfer so for instance music
could you tell us a little bit about the
music but and then I'd like to hear if
anything that you had learned through
competing in sports or practicing sports
translated to music music was a strange
one just because no one else my family
is musical in the slightest you know
especially my sister cannot carry a tune
to save herself but uh yeah I don't know
it was just one of those things where I
I turned it into a competition to be
honest I won a guitar at a snowboard
contests and I was like wow what if I
could just be at a party somewhere and
played one song and one song turned into
like okay I'm now training to be a
guitar player and at that age my world
revolved around like I'm gonna be the
best at this like I don't care I'm gonna
be the best of this and you know one
other thing I do
besides set goals for myself was I just
like pick these battles that just do not
exist there's like the sweetest kid at
the skate park
he he skated for birdhouse and I just I
was like I have to destroy this guy like
how old are you he decided he's dead
like I just built this in my mind and
like he was as sweetest nicest kid ever
this like tall blond kid and I was like
hell-bent on destroying him in my mind I
didn't want to hurt him yeah yeah like
he had my spot and I wanted it I wanted
to be hanging with Tony and doing the
demos and stuff and so at the same time
I was learning guitar there were two
other kids in the neighborhood that
we're learning guitar
and so I would sit on the plane and I
would like stretch my fingers cuz I
couldn't reach all the fret I was like
one day these things are gonna it's
gonna pay off it so I'd stretched my
hands out and because it's difficult to
reach all the threats and then I was on
the plane and I would take my guitar
pick and I would I couldn't upstroke at
the time and so I would I would play the
side of my pants II listen to music I
would scrub the side of my pant leg to
the beat of the song and to the rhythm
of the music and you know to get my
wrist
you know acquainted with that motion and
remember like the one day I show up and
the one kid had been playing guitar it
was very unfair I mean even playing for
10 years or more one day I got my
fulfilling moment where I was like a
Metallica song and he couldn't play the
one riff and I could do you remember the
song it was so sweet yeah so I picked
these battles and it's just Republic
does the hard song it's very hard yeah I
was you know I was just going for
whatever and at the time you know any
kid that picks up a guitar or I guess
Mike and friends were all isn't in
Metallica and it's very guitar riff
driven so it was nice I was always
picking out the leads and things and I
didn't know any chords or why it made
sense
I just learned from guitar tablature off
the internet you know the numbers that
represented the frets and which string
and I'd would just sit there for hours
like okay number two all the way down to
fret five and I would like hours and
then deep down like anybody that picks
up a guitar is like man what would be
like to play on stage and to do this and
from that young age I was like very
self-aware of that like I didn't want
anybody to take a photo of me with the
guitar I didn't want to play for anybody
or let anybody in that world because I
wanted to just show up all of a sudden
be really incredible at it
so that was kind of like how I do things
I'd rather like go and train private
than show up it uh yeah whatever I do
that with a lot of strange things so
that was kind of my way of like you know
practicing keeping it fun and it's nice
you'd make these like I don't know it
really got me to be good at guitar I
like I had this competition and I had
these things going and it really helped
me it's good performing different from
competing and snowboarding obviously
physically it's different but is it
emotionally psychologically different
it's it's yeah it's way different I mean
that the feeling is the same because
it's like that instant gratification of
like doing a big-air do you hear that
there's some large promise I mean this
is yeah are like high school graduations
and we had some pretty amazing
opportunities I play the lead guitar in
a band called bad things it's composed
of mostly friends of mine from the
neighborhood I grew up in and some
amazingly talented guys in LA and you
know we started making our own songs and
we got offered some gigs and things and
there was one moment where we got
invited to go to Lollapalooza I was like
man this is this will be heavy just way
it was for the kids stage so I was like
you know what will be more so poker out
if we just go like play that kids stage
like cuz I don't think I should be on
the main stage I'm just because I'm in
the group does not mean that we should
be giving these scenarios and so we show
up and we you know we did our thing we
had a really great show over the kids
and and then the most amazing thing
happened it was like out of a movie so
the main act on the Grove stage at
Lollapalooza decided they weren't gonna
play they put a big sign out that said
our art will not be displayed here and
their fans completely demolished their
gear and all this all this you know
craziness ensued and there and they
looked around they're like we need a
band to play the mainstage I was like
we're a band you know like motherly like
oh man
and then it was crazy like you come with
us and so there we were I was like oh my
god this is our moment like we got to do
this in there like okay you ready for
this set and so we played one of the
most incredible sets we've ever had you
know we rose to the occasion we had this
amazing set and and just like anyone
that picks up a guitar dreams of being
on stage you dream of that that moment
you're walking off stage and everyone is
cheering for one more song and the best
moment of that as I look at my buddy
this is like do we even have another
song it was incredible it was an
incredible moment in time and yeah so
that got us a lot of credibility in that
space that we actually own the moment
and we played for people they enjoyed it
and that got us a lot of credibility so
then we got offered to tour with Jared
Leto's band thirty Seconds to Mars there
we are in like Romania for 10,000 people
you know it was incredible incredible
you know to open up for them and then we
did a run through the US with a band
called Phantogram but yeah it was it was
just great you know to be playing on
stage doing something different and and
that excitement and and all I'll say is
that you're out on stage with your
friends it's not all on my shoulders you
know I can kind of like you know miss
the pedal or something can happen and go
wrong and it's not the end of the world
in that sense if the show goes on you
have a you have time to like make up for
it you know obviously I'm a
perfectionist so nothing can go wrong I
have to have it perfect but it's just
great to be out there with everyone you
know really combined effort it's not all
all up to me if I play a perfect show
you know the drummer probably didn't
hear the mix and is set and it was a
terrible show so everyone has to come
together to have an amazing performance
so that's that's something different and
you've some very exciting stuff coming
up soon and that is yet other sort of
branch
Shawn white enterprises can you explain
for people it's coming up yeah
it's really incredible it's an event
that's called Aaron style it's coming up
here in Los Angeles February 20th and
21st at the LA Coliseum at Expo Park
it's a sports and music festival that
started about 20 years ago in Austria I
was a competitor at the event I then
became the host of the event and then
some interesting circumstances led me to
being the new owner of the event and my
dream was to take that passion for music
and touring festivals and obviously my
knowledge and experience and love of
snowboarding and combine those two so
down at the at the at the Coliseum we
built the 16 story big air jump what
does an air jump big air jump is just
like one big team stories sixteen story
tall yeah its massive sixteen circus
yeah it's just like one big hit and so
basically the world's best are coming to
compete on it and and then you mix that
with an amazing music lineup we have Jay
Cole Incubus time we have Action Bronson
even cascade will be there which is very
exciting and yeah ASAP Ferg rudimental
really amazing bands all-time low and
and so the idea is that you have this
this mashup I mean obviously my world of
sports is so close to music that like
it's it's just nice to see everybody
come together and experience these
things and it really represents the
culture behind this sport so we have our
fashion technology all these things that
you would find at a festival but the
amazing part is that it's a torso this
actually takes place in Beijing in
December we just had a stop in Austria
and Innsbruck so this is the final stop
of the tour so all of these snowboarders
have been competing this whole entire
time when we crown the winner at this
last event in Los Angeles and we make
this really cool championship ring kind
of way
I feel like I've never been in person to
the X Games I've never been to Coachella
this is my chance to just kind of do
both at once exactly that was the goal
it's cool I mean it's like one of those
things away why didn't this happen
before you know combining the two I mean
if you're watching a tennis match would
it be cool with halfway through it was
really cool it was opportunity for me to
do something brand new and you know
after the last Olympics I didn't win and
I was sitting there and normally you're
kind of flooded with these these offers
of hey you could get some easy money by
doing a deal with so-and-so or doing
this in that and you know I was getting
offers but it definitely wasn't like
what you get when you win and and it was
you know in hindsight it was it was the
perfect opportunity for me to sit down
ago what would I like to do you know and
actually put my own money into it and
build this thing that's that's been my
dream and it's it's really something to
be seen we did it last year it was a
total blowout we had Kendrick Lamar play
and and you know it's really my vision
came together it became real when my mom
showed up she was just like what did you
do like this thing's massive it's 16
stories and yeah you can go to Aaron
style.com
or you can go to front gate tickets calm
and it's great it's 75 dollars look at
you in the gate and then what's really
cool is kids under 10 get him for free
and the whole idea behind that was you
know you can you can come to the event
watch the professionals do their thing
and there's a whole learn to ride area
for whoever wants to ride but you know
hopefully kids will try it out fall in
love with it then go up to the mountains
and it kind of refreshes the sport with
the youth and and all that so and that's
how I got my start I was introduced to
it so I can only hope that you know
somebody comes to the event and becomes
the next so-and-so because you know they
got their start trying out snowboarding
but yeah hope you guys can make it it's
awesome
to want to be any you have a bunch of
commitments coming up to you so I'll ask
just a couple more questions and then
we'll wrap up sure we can talk for hours
and hours and hours I think we'll do a
round piece of that but when you think
of the word successful who's the first
person who comes to mind successful I
can only pick one person no you can make
multiple saltopus
I guess top of my mind right now would
be Andre Agassi you know he's got the
kind of success that you know the
besides the money and the fame and the
things I mean he's got a family he's got
people that care about him if he was in
as troublesome scenario he could call
somebody that would come help him out
with that you know I mean I I measure in
that who do you rely on to tell you when
you're wrong or give you tough love that
type of advice um my brother definitely
Jesse Jesse my brother Jesse I wanted it
we put out an album with the band and I
wanted to thank him in the credits cuz
he was because he told me I couldn't do
it what are you gonna be Kevin Bacon
what are you gonna you know well show
you you know and and it was really
helpful it drove me to actually complete
the album and things but he'll get me
the straight on everything you know
he'll come in and tell me what he really
thinks
how does he deliver that it depends you
know he's either like he'll just make
fun of me until i relent or he'll or
he'll be very sincere about something
and wanna give his input but he he was
the one always doing the new tricks he
introduced me to the sport you know I
was always wanted to do what my older
brother was doing so he's the guy that's
always been that one I go to does he
mention new tricks uh you've always
talked about coming up with good ideas
in the shower I've never had that
experience maybe they're still taking
showers but yeah
when do you tend to come up with new
tricks
um it really depends usually it's by
mistake you go in you're like okay I'm
gonna do the two flips and then I'm
gonna come out and this is exactly where
I'm gonna be wrong completely wrong
anything you end up doing something new
and then you can go Wow well that
actually worked out you know I'm gonna
actually build upon that now you got a
brand new trick that no one's ever done
before or I don't really dream about it
or something like that I had a friend
call me once and told me about a trick
that was a possibility and I completely
disagreed but it got me thinking about
another scenario you know it all comes
from something different but that's
that's usually how it happens for me is
by mistake or I'm just in the right mood
and I want to try something
is there any historical figure that you
would have enjoyed meeting and also we
can also come back to that or just yeah
welcome back hit pause on that one he
said you could have let's see I'll go
with the Billboard again hello you have
billboard you put anything on it that is
not an advertisement for anything that's
coming up immediately soon what would
you put on it put on the Billboard man
probably my dog dog I'm like that guy
that's like my dog is the best-looking
dog mayor B ma y ou RB it's pretty
hilarious
my sister runs it you're in for a treat
if you check it out before your dog's
career yes yeah he's he's yeah he's got
to go on
is there any ass cuz I'm checking out
the obviously the event yeah suggestions
for people who are here listening to
this just something to take with them to
ponder yeah you I don't know I really
kind of based if they you know this is
just some advice for me I guess and it's
it served me very well over the years
but it's the simple lessons that you can
look out for him I mean like when I
wanted to learn a new trick that was
really difficult or I wanted to like in
the beginning of my career like I
couldn't ride what's called switch so
the natural way I ride is left foot
forward it's called regular and if I was
right foot forward it's it's called
goofy but so I'm regular and when I put
my right foot forward that means I'm
riding switch it's my unnatural way of
riding it's like if you're gonna hit a
baseball then you had to kind of go the
opposite way that you would normally do
it and I couldn't do it was super hard I
made myself do it all day every day
until it just became easy it was a
simple thing of like man this is I'm
just gonna do it until it becomes so
easy that it's not hard anymore and that
really paid off for me in the long run
it's kind of like if you can get past
that boredom of like wow I'm not good at
this this is hard I mean I know if
anybody's broken a hand before but you'd
be amazed how quickly you can learn how
to use chopsticks with that other hand I
mean it's it by really just forcing
yourself to do something that you're not
good at until you're really good at it I
mean that simple lesson you know the
simple thing of you know learning what
not to do people want to know how I
learned tricks I'm like man I try them
and I try them and I try them until it
becomes something that's so easy for me
when the world is watching I can do it
you know it's simple simple things I
take and then I guess just keeping your
eyes open for for what's next I mean a
guitar fell into my lap I was just you
know I was I was just aware enough to be
like wow I should try to play this I
should try to become you know great at
this I pick all sorts of fun hobbies for
myself and definitely set goals cuz set
a fun one though too can't be all
serious all the time
where you get the big stuff done Sean
where can people find you on social yeah
and so on to find out more about what
you're up to and you can also mention
where people get the tickets from that
yeah you can go to Aaron style.com and
you can get tickets for the event if you
can't make it to the event it's gonna be
streaming live on go 90 it's Verizon's
new app which really cool you can
download it and then you can not only
check out the event coming up but the
past events to see what the riders are
doing and where their rankings are at
I'm Sean white on Instagram and check it
out spelling for everybody sha un WH ite
I have a same on Facebook and I'm Sean
white snap if you want to get down with
a snapchat what else yeah check it out I
mean it's it's an amazing event and I'm
really proud of it it's something that
you know really speaks to me this board
and and what I'm all about
huh I hope you enjoy awesome well Sean
white everybody thank you so much for
your time
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have
on the podcast but I've been so
impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront com forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of this episode is brought
to you by 99designs
when your business needs a logo website
business card thumbnail or any other
design i recommend checking out
99designs
I use them myself I've used them for
many years I use them to create book
cover prototypes for the 4-hour body
which went on to becoming number one New
York Times best seller I've also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs com forward slash
Tim and right now you can get a free $99
upgrade on your first design so check it
out 99 designs com forward slash Tim
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog calm calm
where you'll find an award-winning blog
tons of audio and video interviews
stories with people like Warren Buffett
and Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park the
books plus much much more follow tim on
twitter at twitter.com/dspacestv or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening
you